[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben ihr habt ja gesagt ich
mache im moment viel süßes da müssen wir
da was herzhaftes her und heute dich
richtig lust auf chicken süß sauer mit
reis also richtig klasse stellen lecker
und das ganze film wird es für euch mit
damit ihr das auch in zukunft immer mal
wieder nach machen könnt für das rezept
habe ich hier eine schüssel mit wasser
das wir dass unsere soße die rühre ich
eben ganz kurz an zum wasser gebe ich
jetzt zuallererst essig wochen ja so
eine süß sauer so so lässig gibt dann
immer schön säure das ist apfel essig es
gebe ich hiermit rainer kommt noch
sojasauce ketchup und gemüsebrühe pulver
mit dazu
[Musik]
so spalte stärker auch schon direkt mit
dazugeben und einrühren und der rest
kommt später das gehen wir jetzt kurz an
die seite und machen hier in unserem
talk weiter da habe ich schon ein
bisschen öl erhitzt übrigens die ganz
genauen mengenangaben wie findet ihr
immer unten in der video beschreibung
und jetzt habe ich hier hähnchen einfach
schöne mundgerechte stücke geschnitten
und brachte das von allen seiten richtig
schön an
[Musik]
das sehen sie bei uns auch nicht so
lange das jetzt graf zwei minuten drin
angebraten weil es sehr klein ist es
geht ganz schnell
und dann habe ich zwiebeln dazu gegeben
und auch noch paprika paprika ist
optional das könnt ihr euch aussuchen
beides jetzt noch so ein bisschen
dünsten lassen und jetzt kommt unsere
soße zum einsatz noch mal ein bisschen
durchrühren und dann einfach dazu geben
und einmal richtig schön verrühren
jetzt noch ein bisschen chili dazu ich
mache da immer nicht so viel und salz
und pfeffer da könnt ihr auch immer
wieder abschmecken
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich das ganze mit offenem
deckel so ein bisschen ein köcheln
lassen das heißt das ganze hat sich
reduziert die soße ist weniger geworden
aber wenn man den vollen geschmack und
wichtig ist dass ihr das mit offenem
deckel macht und dabei eben ständig
unsere damit es nicht am boden anpackt
oder anklebt und es fast wäre hätte ich
eine ganz wichtige zutat kommt jetzt
aber den herd aus und zwar honig das ist
sehr sehr wichtig für den geschmack ihr
könntet auch wenn ihr keinen honig dahab
zucker nehmen das gibt er dann aber ganz
vorne im schritt mit soße das schreibe
ich euch auch noch ganz genau in die
infobox das höre ich jetzt ein und dann
ist das gericht fertig und nebenbei habe
ich auch reis gekocht
[Musik]
nada und fertig ich glaube keine 20
minuten hat es gedauert und nebenbei gab
ja auch noch der reis und ich rate euch
auch definitiv reis dazu zu servieren
das gericht an sich ist sehr sehr würzig
alleinschuldigen der sojasauce und ihm
sehr kräftig auch im geschmack und daher
passt perfekt oder don idee nur dazu da
würde ich direkt mit rein vermengen dass
man das direkt als nudelgericht hat auch
eine sehr gute idee
ich wünsche ich jetzt ganz viel freude
beim nachkochen falls ihr mehr solcher
praktisch nun schnell dritte sehen
möchtet dann hinterlasst diesem video
ein bäumchen nach oben und wir sehen uns
in alter frische bei unserem nächsten
videos eure kiki und der ramsau
[Musik]